let's talk to Ashley in North Carolina
hi Ashley welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show how can Chris and I help hi Dave
how are you doing today
great what's up so my husband and I we
started renting the property we live at
from my father-in-law I'm about five six
years ago and we found out that only the
interest payments had been made on it
and it started to be foreclosed on so
two years ago we ended up having a fight
for them to renew it and thankfully they
did so we were going to purchase the
property from my father-in-law but come
to find out the property it's owed more
on it than it's worth so we cannot get
it switched and on our name so now where
was your water in this position Norwood
you want we have we've put a lot of
money into the property and I had known
about you before then we wouldn't have
why would you put money on Robert you
didn't own well we didn't really
understand all the issues that could
happen due to that and now we're
realizing it since we started listening
to you and we're kind of stuck here at
this point because we put so much money
into it we just wanted to get your
opinion on what we could do actually how
much money did you all put into this
thing we have put about fifteen thousand
into the renovations and we've paid off
about ten thousand dollars so far okay
you paid off ten thousand dollars of the
fifteen so what's owed on it is fifty
thousand dollars what are you what have
you paid $10,000 down on on the house or
on the renovations on the line of credit
we paid ten thousand towards that and we
paid fifteen thousand on renovations
because the place needed to be
completely renovated who had the line of
the line of creditors on the house yes
and my father-in-law's name so you paid
$10,000 of his debt yes and you put
fifteen thousand in addition
and so the line of credit the balance on
it is what now 40 I'm just about 40 yes
and what's the house worth today the
value of it that they have determined
since that has a mobile home on it is
about 36 and 50 was owed on it in turtle
so there's 40 plus another 10 out on it
what's owed on it is only the 40 but um
it was 50 but the value is only about 36
but after our renovations I'm not sure
if that value has gone up any and you
have no idea what he may own the land
correct
well that's altogether that goodness you
all had the intention all along of
buying this from the father-in-law
that's why you did the renovations right
yes we renovated the mobile home okay
how old are you guys 30 and 26 and what
is your household income 77 I your your
this is a real painful thing you've been
through you've got this but there's
multiple problems with the situation
okay one is the big problem is obviously
you've been paying down on a property
you didn't own and you've been
renovating a property you didn't own two
is mobile homes go down in value they do
not go up in value regardless of what
you do to them and so when you renovate
a mobile home by definition that's
throwing good money after bad
and so were you to buy this for 30,000
it's gonna go down in value not up in
value and so even if you could get a
good deal on it I wouldn't buy it and so
I think you've combined
and several things here that don't work
for you
and so the way you ask yourself the
question is in ten years is this going
to have been a good decision and it will
have gone down in value and the answer
is no it would not be a good decision
ten years from now and that tells us
that we don't want to stay in this deal
another minute you actually would be
better off renting somewhere mm-hmm
then what you're doing right now so no
you do not buy this and yes you've lost
the money that you put into it
because you put money into something you
didn't own and you put money into
something that's going down in value
rather than putting money into something
that's going up in value and I'm sorry I
wish I could give you better news but
there's not a trick there's not a twist
there's not a thing we can do that it
changes things here and you know it's
just it's just a bad situation that you
guys threw a lot of money at yeah and it
didn't make it better I'm so sorry but
if I were you I would move on with my
life let him sell this property and get
what he can get for it let him pay his
own bills they're his bills they're not
yours
he now has $40,000 owed on a property
that is worth somewhere around $40,000
well maybe he can get out of it even if
you want to sit there and just rent it
from him and not pay another dime on
anything other than pay rent until you
get ready to buy for a year that's okay
if he wants to sell it now that's okay
but no I would not pay it down further
and Noah would not spend another dime on
maintenance I would not spend another
dime on renovations you are a renter act
like it hmm
if you're gonna stay but I'd prefer you
just moved on to something else and he
can get this sold so you guys can all
put this in your rear view mirror
because the whole process has been
mathematically Ping's yeah yeah and you
know Dave that's that going into
something with that assumption you know
what happens when you assume yeah but we
got it you got to see things clearly
Ashley and you know I heard some little
ones in the background for the sake of
your family and just moving forward
it might be the best thing and your
husband may struggle with that but you
all having a conversation and looking at
this and seeing if what it is and Dave I
like that ten-year decision thing that
time line because it does require us to
look out and am i doing things to keep
me on that path where am i doing things
to derail me and that's the reality yeah
yeah it's uh it's a problem it is so and
so there's a couple things here that you
guys listening can know is if you're
going to do a deal with anyone where you
are counting on ownership do not put
money in it until you have the property
in your name so you don't renovate
someone else's property you don't pay
down on someone else's property ever
there's not a condition under which
that's a good idea
ever ever the second thing is mobile
homes go down in value mathematically
they're a car you sleep in and they go
down in value just like a car does and
you're not gonna win buying them this is
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]